the Joe Rogan experience yeah but the
wide-body GT TRS with the vented fenders
and you can modify you can modify later
you just complained about people who
don't want to modify your complain about
modifying but all that extra effort why
don't they just [ __ ] sell to you with
a stick shift I don't know bro talk to
the Germans I can't [ __ ] wimp there
mate look they make a gt3 with a stick
they maybe Cayman gt4 with a stick they
make the Boxster Spyder with a stick you
can buy a 911 any level of 911 with a
stick well they can't buy the turbo not
the turbo there are the only ones you
can count on though it seems like it's
all going to even Corvette the new
quarter that's double clutch yeah they
said the new gt500 they haven't ruled
out the possibility of having a stick
shift but well so look with the gt500
they just announced this thing it's it's
like 750 horsepower no I've driven a lot
of really powerful manual transmission
cars for me once the car goes over about
500 I don't want to shift anymore really
I don't when I'm driving it on like a
race track as fast as it will go okay
like when I went to test the the the
Corvette zr1 the last front engine one
when it went just completely [ __ ]
bananas right 750 horsepower I went to
Road Atlanta to drive it and they had a
manual and they had an automatic me to
drive and I drove the manual and it was
so [ __ ] fast that I did not feel
comfortable taking my hand off the wheel
to do the shifts that make sense and and
I was like at this level of performance
I really need to have both my hands on
the wheel and I'm a pretty decent driver
I'm not like [ __ ] I'm not the best but
I'm not [ __ ] right and then when I drove
the automatic car I went okay I feel way
more comfortable at this pace with my
hands on the wheel right but this
8-speed automatic they have is the
biggest punk of flamin [ __ ] ever put
into a sports car and so with the c8
with the new one they got rid of the
manual and decided to substantially
improve the auto with a new dual clutch
8-speed which you know for you and for
me is sad that there's no stick it's not
kind to get it because it's just sort of
what progress looks I get it if you're
gonna take it to a race track yeah I do
get it but how many people are taking
their goddamn Corvette to race you know
it's not even really about that it's
sadder it's sadder than that it's really
about how do we get the 0 to 60 time
under three seconds because when they
had the zo6 which was 650 horsepower and
then they had the zr1 which was 750
horsepower they couldn't get it to 60
any faster
Detroit is still so suckin [ __ ] zero
to 60 that that that is important for
some reason and adding a hundred
horsepower didn't change the zero to
sixty because of the front-engine
rear-drive your distraction limited at
that point just burnouts yeah so by
putting the engine in the back you
change the weight distribution now
you've got a dual clutch 8-speed instead
of a manual 7-speed now you can get in
that two-second range 260 which doesn't
improve the experience but it does
improve the number on that magazine
cover with in number but everybody know
I mean how do you not know it's a it's a
[ __ ] fast car ya know it's fast the
gt500 is a real bummer though because
that's a such a muscle car you know it's
a sex your muscle car it's a it's a same
version of the Tremec dual clutch from
the corvette is it as in the Mustang
yeah it has a different number of gears
incidentally it has a set it's a 7-speed
in the Mustang in an 8-speed in the
Corvette but it's same family of brand
new Tremec dual clutch gearboxes what
has a wider contact with the tires I
don't know what the Mustangs got if I
had to guess you see a narrower right if
I had to guess the Mustang had water see
eight Corvettes 305 rears that is yeah
it's not you know with a mid-engine car
what is interesting about a mid-engine
car as you find this a lot I bet if you
went out and looked at a Ferrari like a
four or five eight or something you'd be
shocked at how narrow the tires are
really yeah when you do a mid-engine car
you can give up a lot of that huge fat
rear rubber because the weight
distribution doesn't necessitate it
wait.you entire tire sizes are typically
chosen by the weight distribution of the
car so like your 911 euro air cooled car
your old one right so you got big fat
rears and you've got relatively skinny
fronts that's because that engine is
over the rears so in a mid-engined like
I just looked this up for an unrelated
thing in the four five eight the front
tires are only two 45s on that and the
rear tires are 305 so where is a
Corvette
your front tires are like 275 the old
Corvette front tires are 275 rears like
a 335 that that difference in weight
distribution is how big of a difference
you need in tires weary sense the that's
you know have you driven the gt500 - no
I didn't get to do it yet unfortunately
it looks fun someone posted a video it
ran a 10-6 quarter-mile out of the box
it's crazy as [ __ ] it's a very very fast
I cannot believe some of the cars that
people can just buy well speaking of
which that Porsche that you sent me the
video yet I can it's too tight I gotta
say it I can't I can't take on yeah
don't wanna [ __ ] that one up for years
that thing looks preposterous okay look
I know how preposterous my Tesla is I
tell everybody when they say oh you know
you have really fast cars might see that
one right there yeah the one that looks
like a dad car that's that one blows all
yeah and you
[Applause]